por esta vez estos atascos en la
carretera de nueva delhi son una buena
señal ya que miles de agricultores
vuelven a sus pueblos tras lograr que el
gobierno cediera a sus últimas demandas
en vista de las promesas hechas por el
gobierno hemos decidido suspender
nuestras protestas nos reuniremos el 15
de enero y si estas promesas no se han
cumplido volveremos a manifestarnos
[Música]
hace más de un año miles de agricultores
indios salieron a las calles en todo el
país pidiendo la retirada de las leyes
agrícolas aprobadas por el parlament o
legislación que permitía a los
agricultores vender sus productos a
compradores de su elección pero sin la
garantía de los precios fijados por el
estado los pequeños productores temían
quedar a merced de las grandes empresas
y tener que vender sus productos más
baratos ante la magnitud de la protesta
el primer ministro indio anunció la
retirada de estas leyes el mes pasado
narendra modi también acaba de acordar
el pago de indemnizaciones para las
familias de aquellos que murieron
durante las protestas y para detener en
la persecución contra algunos de ellos
se inclinaron ante el pueblo y los
agricultores salvamos la democracia
desde que llegó al poder en 2014
narendra modi nunca ha accedido ante
protestas pero el primer ministro quiere
mantener la ventaja en los estados de
punjab y uttar pradesh donde se
celebrarán elecciones clave en unos y de
dónde proceden muchos de los
agricultores que participaron en el
movimiento